all right ted thank you for that well as
the temperatures rise around the valley
so do air conditioning repair calls one
local technician says he is busy with
requests but the supply chain shortage
is holding him up
chris wiley says the summer season is
one of the busiest times of the year for
him in 2013 he started his own business
but he says work is getting harder to
finish it's not like it was like five
years ago where you could just go pick
up
units and just know that they would be
there
i've had several suppliers just be out
of units for an entire month wiley says
many of the items he needs to complete
his work are on back order the even
harder part he says is relaying that
message to the client this is the
situation and you're gonna have to wait
that's all you can do having air
conditioning is not a luxury it is a it
is a necessity michael fuhrman has been
living in las vegas for over 30 years
and knows all too well those
uncomfortable nights when your cooling
system shuts down when it's this hot
even putting on the fans won't help
ferman recently bought a home but the ac
unit was 20 years old he says being
proactive saved him we had it checked
out and there were some issues but
nothing
major but just enough that i didn't want
to take a chance on another season so he
got it taken care of before the heat a
wise choice wiley says to avoid a sweaty
situation with unknown repair timelines
and when you call for an ac problem it's
an emergency call it's not a you know
it's not something
most people don't don't plan
don't plan for their units to break in
all right wiley says he currently has
three major orders one of those has been
on hold for about a month now he tells
us the best thing to do to avoid getting
into this problem is to get your ac unit
checked out as often as possible and of
course don't forget to replace the
filters that alone could save you big
bucks